I hope you're sitting down because I
have some shocking news to report
it appears that despite what we saw at
the end of infinity war
spider-man is in fact not dead and
starring in a new movie called far from
home we took an extremely close look at
the first trailer to track down all the
hidden secrets and easter eggs and also
to figure out why everyone was back to
being alive instead of interdimensional
ash flakes let's jump into it before we
get into the meat of the trailer we
first got to ask does anyone know when
this is actually taking place after all
we did see a whole lot of these
characters blow away like so much
proverbial dust in the wind and now
we're all kind of naturally assuming
this is post endgame and the Avengers
have set everything right there's
nothing here that definitely confirms
that's the case this could be taking
place between the events of homecoming
and infinity war after all notice that
in this close-up shot of Peters passport
they haven't included the year along
with the other dates maybe they left it
off because it would let us know that
this is happening earlier than we
assumed or even in an alternate timeline
hey we're in a post spider-verse world
okay
anything is possible probably the
biggest story here is that the far from
home trailer gives us our very first
look at Jake Gyllenhaal's Mysterio both
with and without his iconic fishbowl
helmet in the comics Mysterio is
typically a super villain who uses
powers of illusion magic in hypnotism
in fact he serves as one of spider-man's
main adversaries yet here he appears to
be helping our hero seems likely we'll
get some kind of late in the game change
of heart or betrayal
note that when Mysterio uses magic to
fight the water monster we see similar
arcane symbols appear as we do when
Doctor Strange uses magic hmmm curious
could these two become future rivals Doc
Strange is the sorcerer supreme I
wouldn't want to go up against that if I
was just another sorcerer just saying we
also discovered that Peters Aunt May may
be striking up a new romance with Tony
Stark's right-hand man
happy hogan how do we feel about this do
we ship this do kids still say that
almost definitely not we know for a fact
that Pete and his friends visit at least
two far-flung destinations Venice and
London and while he's on the road
Pete meets up with the founder of The
Avengers Nick Fury who apparently also
did not really die in the snap plus all
of his spy skills are clearly intact he
snuck into a room full of sleeping teens
fired a dart gun and had a full
conversation with Peter Parker without
waking anyone up the trailer indicates
that the villains in this new film will
be the elementals in the comics they're
a team of four whose powers allow them
to control natural forces there's
Hellfire who generates flames
hydron who controls water magnum who
manipulates earth and rocks and Zephyr
who controls air but it's entirely
possible that none of the elementals we
see in the film will actually be the
original comic book versions of these
characters many fans have speculated
that these villains are actually not the
original elementals at all but Moulton
man Hydra man and Sandman who all have
similar powers to the ones we see on
display Plus Hellfire already appeared
on TVs agents of shield bolstering this
theory check out this boat floating
behind Ned in Venice it's identified as
a SM - one - this could be a reference
to amazing spider-man issue - one -
which was the first to feature you
guessed it hydro man oh and check out
this shot of Nick Fury fighting the
movies rock monster who's the mysterious
woman fighting alongside him the most
probable candidate is Cobie Smulders aka
Maria hill she's credited as appearing
in far from home after also vanishing
alongside Nick in the snap but we think
this could also be Sharon Carter aka
agent 13 we last saw her aiding Captain
America and Civil War but what if this
is actually Captain Marvel back
alongside Nick Fury maybe they just
reunited post endgame and fury has
called in some big guns to deal with
this rock creature she has blonde hair
it's totally possible
let's talk suits the trailer shows off
not one but two new suits
spider-man still has his wings from the
first movie but this suit now appears to
be red and black instead of classic blue
and red plus we also get the debut of
Spidey's new stealth suit this all black
offering kind of resembles the
spider-man noir looked from into the
spider verse and appears to be a lot
more low-tech than the Tony Stark suit
we've seen in the past they may want to
introduce Hydra man and Sandman because
those characters are former members of
the comic books sinister six the
supervillain group that Sony has long
dreamed of bringing to the big screen
also featured in the sinister six
vulture who remains alive and in prison
and who we know appears in some capacity
in this film also check out this
building under construction behind
Spidey when he's swinging through New
York now maybe they're just cleaning up
after the destruction of the snap we see
a crane in Venice - backing up the
theory that the whole world is being
slowly rebuilt but it looks like a new
tower could be replacing the Avengers
Tower which of course we saw Tony
leaving for good at the end of
homecoming
perhaps this will one day serve as the
Baxter building
the iconic home base of a certain
fantastic squad of four heroes early on
happy tells Peter you're all alone which
sounds kind of odd because Happy's boss
Tony was kind of looking out for
spider-man until now could this mean
that Tony Stark has stepped away from
public life and ceased to be Iron Man or
worse could something have happened to
Tony I don't want to think about it
let's let's move on a few more fun
details we picked up did you hear the
classic Spiderman TV theme now performed
as an orchestral score that was awesome
in the quick shot of Peters passport we
see that his birthday is August 10th the
character of spider-man first appeared
in the August 1962 issue of Marvel's
amazing fantasy so this checks out in
the quick shot of Peters luggage note
that it has the monogram BFP
this is most likely Ben F Parker aka
Peters Uncle Ben oh that's sweet
that was just about everything we saw
but we don't know everything just most
things so if you notice something we
didn't mention hit us up in the comments
and let us hear about it